So I'm Felipe Lobelo,
I'm a preventive medicine doctor and I work at the Emory School Public Health,
the Hubert Department of Global Health and I direct
the Exercise Medicine Research Center.
The mission really is to evaluate the implementation of the Exercises Medicine in
Global Initiative which in a nutshell is
trying to make physical activity part of health care.
Really, when you think about
main risk factors for chronic disease and mortality around the world,
inactivity has been sort of overlooked.
And what we're trying to do here is to make sure
that physicians and healthcare systems assess
patients physical activity and provide
some recommendations or counseling to help them improve physical activity.
And as a result, improve your health.
Absolutely, so we see mHealth and patient
generated data as really
critical to the implementation of the Exercise Medicine Initiative.
For the last few years,
some healthcare systems have started implementing
physical activity questions in their electronic medical records,
but as many of you know,
there's a lot of action around using
wearable devices to objectively measure people's physical activity level.
And some health systems are starting to
pilot test implementation of these data to guide clinical counseling.
Now, these are really early stages in this period and there's a lot of questions.
We typically refer to this as the Wild Wild West of mHelp because issues around validity,
and privacy, and interpretation of the data,
and interoperability are really at the cross of making this routine care.
Yes, there's a number of initiatives and groups that are actively
working to solve some of these issues and to improve not only the quality of the data,
but also the use of it.
So in terms of the quality and the standardization of different devices,
there's a number of projects going on that are trying to essentially assess,
no the mean error,
which devices are more accurate than others.
There's also different use cases depending on
the clinical population you may want to choose one device over the other.
There's really no central repository of these data or these recommendations,
but the American College Sports Medicine,
the CTA standards section,
the American Heart Association and others are
actively working to solve some of those issues.
At the end of the day like any other measurement in clinical care,
in medicine, is not going to be perfect,
there's going to be some error.
But we think that at least the process needs to be streamlined and so,
critical aspects around data standardization need to be in place.
Yes, so I was lucky enough to connect with a group of brilliant students that had
a passion for this area and also the knowledge and the
expertise to at least start to solve some of these problems.
So, one of the issues that we have is that,
there is sort of bring your own approach to patient generated data.
In some cases, a clinician may want to prescribe if he will,
a certain device to assess activity,
but for the most part,
this is a consumer oriented industry and patients are going to have
a device and they want to have that data provide some deep,
taking into account with clinical counseling,
so the main aspect of the project the students worked on,
was to try to integrate different sources of
data from different devices into the electronic medical record.
And also, make sure that
the critical useful aspects of
the data are being presented to the clinician in a simple way.
Because as you know,
these devices collect a lot of data.
There's a lot of noise and you really want
the meaningful use aspect of this to become what gets integrated into FHIR,
so that was the main objective of that project.
Yes. So essentially, the students were able to capture the data on the back end of
a few wearable devices that we identified as being
accurate and appropriate for
these different use cases and in lifestyle medicine and counseling.
And then, we made sure that the data was
transformed in a way that was connected to public health guidelines.
Typically, these devices collect steps but
the recommendations from the CDC and
other public health organizations are not really around steps,
are around minutes of physical activity per week.
So, we made a transformation of the students work on transforming
that data from different metric steps into minutes of
moderate to vigorous physical activity and draw a line
or set the standard for what is the appropriate weekly dose,
if you will, recommended by
public health organizations and make sure that that visualization aspect of
the data was clear as we intend to migrate this data into electronic medical records.
So here you can see that once the data is
being capture from the back end of the wearable device that we selected,
then it needs to be transformed from the metric
that the device uses into minutes of physical activity per week.
And then, you have weekly,
daily data being captured.
And then, you have to combine the daily data into a weekly metric.
Because, the volume of activity per week is the recommended public health guideline.
So, when you combine weekly data into,
or daily data into a weekly standard of
150 minutes of moderate to vigorous physical activity,
then you can see a line that essentially helps a clinician identify if for that week,
that patient met the recommended dose of activity.
In addition to the total dose of activity per week,
you also have the intensity of activity.
So again, the recommendation is for 150 minutes of moderate,
or vigorous exercise, or physical activity.
And in essence, vigorous minutes count twice.
So, plus part of this project,
the metrics need to be adjusted so that
minutes of moderate intensity activity are combined.
And you can see here in a different color,
with minutes of vigorous intensity activity in order
to come up with the recommended public health metrics.
So, using different visualization aspects, colors,
a threshold line that helps the clinician
identify what's a dose and whether that patient is meeting that dose or not.
Should be able to simplify the process of
interpreting that data in leading into the counseling,
that the clinician can provide to that patient.
My pleasure Mark and thanks for inviting me to work with this class and your students.
It's a great opportunity to combine different expertise
and issues around the interoperability
of mobile health and looking forward to working in more of these projects.